ragazzi allora è uscito un gioco che
sarebbe il sequel di le for that che un
liscio di ho giocato di più nella mia
vita al computer ai tempi volevo provare
ragazzi con nichi e lowry disappunto
vediamo che cosa esce fuori e spero che
vi piaccia buona visione ragazzi allora
io mi scelgo a ognuno ha delle rose 16
per cento di munizioni io voglio cuore
salute velocità di movimento raga e
vangelo cioè uno che si chiama e vangelo
io lo show degli stessi capelli si
chiama e vangelo ma come fai a non
scegliere questa questione delle armi
veramente oscene comunque sono poco
hanno cagare le armi
l'escluso questo aprendo la porta aperta
già
date madonna ragazze e che per che mi
ricordi sono giocate fortunate
18 giu pesante del suo gioco è sia
nostalgia certa nostalgia ma le armi
decenti le troviamo in giro sensi ma
sono rare delle più compatto le monete
noi dobbiamo prendere queste bene perché
da che cosa è male ma ne sono condivisi
tra tutti le armi no quindi fai
attenzione alla diga è lui a salvarli
una domanda a rapirlo pesato e gli oro
in 10
la domanda che volevo fare e come mai la
grafica è più brutta di colore gli ha
fornito
aiuto questa è una gara che poteva
sapere la casa aprono l'anno appena esce
no è una pistola di me ma qui ci sono
degli usi più scarsi aiuti fondani
guarda ti spedisce il cuore dell'arma
questa cosa non comune poi c'è quella
verde quella bio nave
c'è uno un po grosso qua a casa da
mister il e per c'era sempre un po
grosso no no no no no no no
ma non si capisce un cavolo che ha
parlato malissimo addosso ma se posso
giocare ragazzi non capirete niente nel
video è normale ragazzo si capisce una
sega
io
ei ragazzi qua c'è gente se mi date una
volta rimane convinta
a scusa scusa svolta maxim c'è un
bordello 18 ragazzi di farci di
pareggiare al bordello
esigenza si è
attivato maxim bravo maxim che arrivano
il miliardo di persone
e di avvisare chiunque a licata ragazzo
bravo max in che
prediligono grosso io e morto a madonna
come esploso tra lo so ma da una ragazza
un po di arma in questo sangue se
teniamo i comandi volete aperto grazie
proprio fare questa cosa
agi9
ok quindi ma non c'è tipo la flai la
face lightman la torcia che non si vede
una sega e con il problema senza
automatismi
no sono caduto aiuto ragazzi amici amici
9 che
siamo fortissimi tutti caduti tutti i
caduti
abbiamo un neurone in due tanto ci stava
stava aiutando mi ha guardato da amici
di
sempre anche quando giocavo a calcio
siciliano per ustica
e lavorati ragazzi che poi non ha
aiutato e poi mi sono alzato la sola
bellissimo quali chiede un kit di
attrezzi mi spiegate le cose anche se
non mio dio è va beh ma questo bug rossi
pd del trentino che s'era che aspetta
c'è una cassa quasi
stazionaria leggio maturo belle ragazze
la mia arma è diventata blu cosa devo
fare qua e spara spara più forte tanica
di pensa che ce ne fa che faccio
qualora io ce l'ho quasi coppa in mano
tale quando eccola qua maxime per te
gli ha salvato la faccia porto detto
altri atterrato maxim lascio io l'hanno
fatto niente è uscito fuori detonante
atterrato maxim e non ho fatto niente
lui non lo sa adesso vado ad aiutarlo e
passo per come l'eroe di turno non lo sa
pure il mondo se brescia eccolo qua
maxim ci penso io non lo sai cosa è
successo ma guarda che adesso ti aiuta
prego prego lunedì veri che mi è
riconoscente perché lui sa che io sono
un amico massimo e con gli altri valori
e madonna maxim ma anche sta riposando
tanto la prima volta che la media c'è
uno grosso la
2 io so solo una mazza da baseball che
faccio è uno che ha fatto esplodere
l'altro ragazzi io sono la mazza da
baseball va bene così brano finiti
colpirà aiuto ma io fino a mais farfan è
ovvio ma
ci sono due giganti la come cazzo ti
faccio fuori voleva che avevate un
atmosfera
gotica oggi sono qua colpisce le abbiamo
di fianco era che volendo quindi con se
vi interessa qua è più nei conti
ama tanto ogni colpo al non sono
unificati madonna che casinò ma in tutti
i prenditori perché solo tu no sempre
imitabili potrò fare agli altri
no non troppo niente non troppo incerto
e poi troppo agli altri questo è lo
spirito con il quale la propria non ero
io per me è
morto morto a symbola costa di sync è
strano perché abbina fila non è lui è
lui
la famiglia ha capito fratello la nostra
testa non devi spaccarla però c'era un
tizio lino mesto 6 visto capito c'è
anche la nostra testa
maxine ha scritto sorli poverino
ha poi prendere a pugni una forma vabbè
bellissimo tutto a posto ragazzi la
porta avanti rimasto fuori let's go on
completata completata bravo maxi bravo
maxim sterminatori di animati un altro
quello che ora è arrivato l'ho ucciso io
bellissimo mazzini ha risposto però
grazie ne aveva scritto come minimo su
capire solo io non l'ho capito grazie
[Musica]
guarda ragazzi visto comprendere la
situazione
ragazzi se abbiamo perso la partita
giovani bomba
si dice non so parlare sentire
qualcuno andato avanti perché è il
platino di gente che succede perché
perché ho già parlato e lordo cioè agli
uccelli ragazzi ma conveniva stare qua
sopra di avati colpi di share nel senso
giusto riferire forse non lo so dove è
morto se incastrato nelle tegole e morto
nelle tecnologie è stato comunque sono
sceso alla fine con un pirla secoli
talismano a
caracas lo stesso rumore mediatica no no
no c'è un
c'è uno un po grosso amici orco è orco
zio possono fare battute poco per li
prendi con questo nome ricorso
ragazzi io mi mi allontanerei di quanto
abbiamo perso siamo solo all'entrata
pensa te e ti ricordi il coltellino che
mandato all'inizio la guardare essere un
minuto ecco lo fai
l'inter chiude
solo morendo tutto a posto avete squillo
però non ci piace che non ho tranquillo
basta tirare un coltello tranquillo pato
ai di chi sei tutti noi destra sei tutti
noi la salma c'è si sentì mezzo che sei
proprio
adesso lo picchio light
pro x è stato ivan evangelo chiede aiuto
tutti gli altri sono quelli altrimenti
io sono stato in cui ho
mai avuto tocco minuzzo mamma mi stanno
arrivando sta arrivando la casta
arrivando sta arrivando perché avevano
praticato di strapparsi il cuore
lanciarci addosso
ecco
madonna maxim
marcatura e aiuti nella tua vita
mica maxim che è imploso compiono le
invidia che egli esplosa subito la
schiena come
madonna ma muoviti prato i due anche
spostarsi deriva un meteorite in patria
adesso però è relativo comunque
bellissimo non poteva più fare niente
quando abbiamo avvisato ha detto mica
senti che bossi
ma la città della moda ma dove orc
arriva mica pistola più che a pistoia
per scopi che perdiamo soldi vediamo
adesso che ne so io non li so leggere
eccola mica visto avrai tra capirono
paura di morir si sono a roma che o su
cinque è impossibile dirlo sembra un
sacchetto di patatine
aiuto c'è una grossa qua a quanto è
morto
non è anche dalle tremende sia rivisto
il 5
tutti e tre si è vero bravo tu quel
pieno di roba questo mio è mio amico
stanno soffrendo mese
fa ma è questa la carta da capo per
oneroso madonna che bella questa arma
ragazzi bellissima sicuri e paura che
non ho colpi madonna a reggio ciao
ragazzi quest'anno dalle mie scarpe
l'arma della storia di un urto arriva
loro bene ma non so se sai che è
arrivato quello grosso di prima io non
colpite la pistolina anche dentro la
piccolina tra non ti preoccupare ottima
che ho perso ragazzi st pizarro nel
normale spara un miliardo di colpi al
secondo
la tesi motivo ti devi salvare di nuovo
ecco la
debacle e di ombra tensione sta ponendo
sta morendo poi chi dall'alto gli dà
come caffè spavento si diventa sta visto
dai ragazzi c'è la pista che spara alla
velocità della luce in siberia dell'iti
che dai calpesta i kimono non tira ma
qui va bene così parlava
e non ti va l'ultimo schiaffo sul nuovo
spaccato o sbagliate nord le cascate in
faccia
zaia sta morendo
non mi metterei laurito dello stesso
ecco la donna raga non abbiamo vita
abbiamo uno sputo premorto è bot ma dove
cazzo festeggiato maxim
peccato perché era molto forte per te
che cuoce della roma se
l'interesse sempre aiutare trova il
primo una nuova senza ritornato massimo
adesso studio mi sono stirato piano i
soldi qua
no ragazza erano vincere questa non è
male nella roccia forse la wii ci sono
pagato perché ha fatto un rumore strano
mondo un progetto ragazzi vuole aiutare
voi combattete ma non c'è la senti qua
ci deve stare vicino e speriamo perché
non ho più colpi da un'ora l'avevo
capito
non tenesse neanche lamentando la 45
esatto
eccoci ai mascherate ma allora ma allora
ma allora fa abbiamo preso pochi
schiaffi all'acqua e poi in sparato a
terra baruch all 80 grazie maxim ha
abbandonato la partita ma chissà perché
è questa la mia rende tutto molto
inquietante
occhio agli uccelli
così prima ma ho preso una botta in
faccia ragazzi guardaroba guarda i nuovi
denti che mi ha fatto
bloccati senza pagata l'altro theatro
uno schiaffone poi è morto insieme a
terra
adesso al vino estenderà come si trovano
i meno tranquillo per costare troppo
forte non segua dormono tra l'altro ok
ne va beh ma allora è rotto il cazzo
possibile sono stato io stavolta niente
adesso tocca all'aula
dic italiani nato 82 volte
che mette pressione ammette
la lista dove dove non è che dietro
queste camminando sul capitale dove la
farsa ok
abbiamo ammazzato di chi fa la solita si
celebra volatile ma non è un bravo la
zebra volatile
è proprio quello di
fallita chissà per quale motivo è
arrivato il boomer
[Musica]
vaccini fanno male
se quando si fa il faccino mi fa male il
braccio era genica ecco l'inter i nove
colpi il beni fratello dove sei e
morto questo ti prego
gli ho tirato una tumori bombola giù
perché sugli uccelli fratello
gianni non ho fatto niente ottone anche
sparato e il master in mezzo
[Risate]
arriva il boomer
ai margini ma per niente sta bloccando
farisei che il dormiente lo so ma mi ha
fatto malissimo io sicuramente con
iniezione live però non aver finito con
la
mamma mia che grandi che siamo ragazzi
ce l'abbiamo fatta dopo 200 tentativi ce
l'abbiamo fatta ma che volete
sì
perché
c'è la mia un faccio
da quando non ricopriva [ __ ] con
ricordi si come dei pazzi sempre
ok ci siamo allora
ok è bellissimo non penso
dio mio i ragazzi non sarà più bisogno
di belfort blog abbiamo fatto anche un
altro ma non è in questo video tra un
altro video ovviamente credo vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi mettete un bel commento
a sotto anche un brutto momento fatemelo
volete passa che lasciate mi piace di
sky al canale perché sono così
importanti è il comando e non c ial come
sempre al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]
ma